randy weingarten who's the president of
the teachers union and she is a real
piece of work uh she gave a speech about
critical race theory whether they're
teaching it or not or whether they plan
to teach or not or how important it is
or isn't
let's take a look critical race theory
is not taught in elementary schools
or middle schools or high schools
it's a method of examination
taught in law school and in college
that helps analyze whether systemic
racism exists and in particular
whether it has an effect on law and
public
policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history
okay on one hand she's telling us it's
not taught and then she's also telling
us that the people trying to stop it
are trying to stop the truth from being
taught so
a little inconsistency there i mean she
is an extraordinary liar
the idea that cultural warriors are
doing this to stop
any honest assessment of race or racism
be taught is complete nonsense the new
meme that they have is oh they don't
want anyone to discuss
race or anything like that we all know
that's not true i have no doubt that
everyone
in these four little boxes here was
taught about racism and slavery
and mlk and jim crow laws and everything
else
carlin you've been like at the lead
fight against this thing
um randy weingarten go
yeah i mean she's absolutely lying and
if anyone has any questions about this i
actually on my youtube channel right now
have a recording of an eighth grade
class
in which they were teaching critical
race theories so i have it on video i
know exactly how it's being taught
now the problem is that they are not
teaching critical race theory in k-12
schools in the same way that they're
teaching it in colleges and universities
so what they do in k-12 schools is they
just get little nuggets in there they
like what they did in this eighth grade
class is they said
if you agree with the pledge of
allegiance and you want society to be
fair and just
then you need to believe in equity
versus equality because we want everyone
to have the same outcomes
they just plant these little nuggets all
the way through the educational
experience so they're primed when they
go to college
but i'll tell you this too one of the
state bill i worked on the state bill in
new hampshire that was unfortunately
watered down by my rhino governor chris
sununu but before it was watered down it
actually had a provision in it that said
you can teach every concept in this bill
you just have to teach it from an
objective
fashion you cannot be an activist you
cannot teach things as factually true
that are not factually true
and so the teachers unions are not
telling the truth about these bills
and what they cover you can still teach
about slavery you can still teach about
the holocaust
these are just downright lies right it's
just extraordinary we're not teaching it
and also it must be taught
uh viva i think you saw the op-ed piece
in the times a couple days ago by david
french and a bunch of other people
basically saying that these anti-crt
laws that certain states are passing are
bad ideas
but to me uh we don't teach nazism right
we don't teach everyone to be nazis
you know what we say on my channel with
robert barnes confession through
projection and you watch what she just
said there
half of it is pure projection in the
idea of trying to bully people into
silence
and demonize discourse that is i say
this from an
absolute outsider's perspective i have
seen the evolution of crt
in the united states over the last two
years what she described as what the
adversaries are trying to do to her is
exactly what they are trying to do
to anybody who oppose crt in schooling
and
her double speak that we don't teach it
in in elementary school or whatever
but it's taught in universities well
they give it another word in
universities but there
we've seen it now and we've seen
admissions from the teacher saying we
want to teach it
and if you oppose it you are the uh or
the bigot and the phobe and the iss
but the accusation is exactly what they
are doing themselves
walter since i'm guessing we all agree
that she's lying here what do we do
about all of the liars that it seems
like
almost everyone in charge of everything
important right now
is an abject liar and i always quote
that alexander sultan it's in quote
they know they're lying we know they're
lying they know we know they're lying
and they continue to lie
it's like there's no shame there's
nothing we can do to shame her
she's not going to stop well first of
all in her case
america needs to see more of her because
because she is everything that every
child
grows up hating about public school
teachers
she's pedantic smug she talks down to
people
she pretends that she's you know
infallible when you can
see right through half of her things
she's not logically consistent
we need the liars especially when
they're as bad as heard just keep
lying because this tactic of denying
that something exists
always breeds a very obvious counter
move proving that it does
and it's a very easy thing to do
and so as if they're going to go with
this you know
it's not happening what you know it's do
you see any uh
monster in the room here while it stands
over their shoulder
they're gonna lose walter i got a title
for your next book well you just came up
with it yourself but just keep lying
like to me that's yeah maybe that's the
meme that we need to be pushing for all
these people instead of keep calling
them liars it's yeah
keep lying guys keep lying